Alyson I want to start with you I was so
intrigued to learn NASA is not some
thing that you just learned about to
write this movie it's in your blood your
grandparents worked at NASA and you've
also been very involved in these kinds
of issues as well tell us about that yes
I grew up outside Cape Canaveral and my
grandfather worked on a mercury capsule
and my grandmother showed up to bring
him lunch one day and saw a sign that
said learn how to use computers and so
she became a programmer at NASA and then
when I was in eighth grade they
recruited dorks like me who were good at
math and science to work at NASA so I
spent all of high school busing up there
and working everything from programming
to building circuit boards to the
payload Bay so it's been amazing to work
on this project so at what point did you
hear about these three women did it take
the book that was written about them for
you to know their story it did
essentially Donna gelati had optioned
the book from Margo and called my
manager and said do you know anyone that
can write math and science and he said I
have someone who worked at NASA and so
they sent me the story and I just
thought how is this possible we don't
know these women and I knew women and
diversity had been a big part of NASA
but I'd never heard these three stories
before Jenna what intrigued you and
Peter turned in about the script that
you read in the story that you heard
well we had made a movie with Ted Murphy
his first movie is st. Vincent so Ted
Melfi intrigued us first of all before I
had read the script and then we read the
script and it's just you know it's
undeniable when you read something like
this and you realize you don't know
anything about it and how could that
possibly be true and the characters were
so compelling and you know it just felt
like an inevitable must-do film and Ted
I'm such a fan of st. Vincent your film
with Bill Murray and Melissa McCarthy
and Nomi watts are so great this is so
different what were you excited to to
take on as far as a different tone and a
different kind of story from your last
film well I mean I when I first read the
script it was very dramatic and Allison
done an amazing job with the characters
but I wanted to infuse a sense of comedy
in it because that's just how I see Life
right
I think life is very funny for some
reason no but my mom would always tell
me growing up you don't have to make
time for for tears you know tears are
born tears come they come with life
someone's gonna get sick someone's gonna
die you're gonna fail at times thanks
mom but anyway I just thought of that
but you have to make time for laughing
you have to make time to find laughter
so I want to infuse a sense of comedy
into what Alice and it already did and
so I tried to blend the two of them and
it gave me a chance to work on both
aspects of myself
give me an exciting genetic site so it
was very challenging taraji you were
very fortunate in that of the three lead
characters the woman that you play
Katherine Johnson is the one that's
still with us what were you able to
learn by talking to her and talking to
her family members I just learned that
during a time where she had all the
obstacles stacked against her the women
never complained when I spoke to her you
know I'm a modern day woman I have a lot
of attitude and I'm gonna tell you
what's on my mind and back then you did
not have that luxury
you know because you could very well be
strange strange fruit hanging from a
tree so what I found very interesting is
that I tried to make it about that and I
was like but wasn't it hard and you
didn't have your rights and and she just
you know she's like that's just the way
things were I just put my head down and
I went to work and you know I think
about me in this industry and you know
always get asked a question um you know
how it so hard for black women in the
industry and you know if I chose to make
that my story with our own six
properties you know what I mean now I
may have not always been number one on
the call sheet but maybe I wasn't ready
you know but I don't you know I loved
that's the one thing I took away from
her don't complain about the obstacles
we all have obstacles are you gonna be a
part of the problem of the solution and
the only way you're a part of the
solution is you got to do the work you
know and then you look up one day and
the accolades come and you know she
didn't
expect this she was just going to work
everyday thankful to God that she had a
job and the career that she studied she
never walked in like yeah I'm gonna
change the world you know it just
happened and she was prepared and
opportunity met preparation and she
changed the course of history and that
can happen when you pay attention to
finding solutions one physical move that
you do as Catherine is the you know the
pushing up of the glasses and I just
love it every time you do it it's like
an exclamation point to a sentence but
it also kind of like reminds us all of
the nerdiness is was that based in fact
it or is that something that you guys
decided to do well only well yes that
was with the help of Ted he was
fascinated with the whole glasses thing
but you know when you're studying a
person what we only had like an hour and
a half maybe two hours with her when we
went to meet her and so I was like a
little sponge I watched everything and I
just remember her mannerism was just
very you know she's she's 98 now so
she's very fragile but that mind is very
sharp
she had Scrabble game Monopoly
underneath her sofa it was like I would
love to play Scrabble with her she
kicked my butt but no but um you know I
had a I just had a little amount of time
to like pay attention to her so I never
took my eyes off of her and then to have
her family come up to me like oh my god
you played my grandma to a tee like all
of her mannerisms and there's like wow I
was really paying attention huh yes and
Octavia I loved I loved the character of
mrs. Vaughn because she walks this line
of advocating for herself and asserting
what she wants and also for all the
women that she's looking after but also
doing it in a delicate way so as not to
upset an apple cart right what did you
find fascinating about her and the way
that she carried herself in the
workplace she and I are so different
well like taraji said we're contemporary
women and we're so used to being able to
say what we need because we have that
agent
see that they did not have in that time
period but playing Dorothy taught me so
much about having a voice and how Ted
directed this film the way the script
was set up what I'm learning with what's
happening in the world right now is that
confrontation does not lead to solving
problems because if you have a finger in
your face constantly you are not going
to hear the other person but if that
thing the finger is down and you just
have a conversation you're more apt to
hear and I learned that about that quiet
resolve that these women had and it it
just made me realize that you know there
is a responsibility that we have but
also how to navigate things that you
don't have to be confrontational and
still be effective
Peter the film's so definitely goes back
and forth between the workplace for
these three women and also their home
lives can you talk about what your goals
were as far as cutting back and forth
between those two milieu and then also
did you cut differently within a work
scene and a home scene did you want to
give it a more leisurely pace for
instance in the domestic scenes yeah no
not really the thing that's most
important to me is that things be
authentic and if the performances are
authentic then the audience is just into
the film and they're not thinking about
the film they're just having it unfold
and that's all that really mattered to
me the balancing of the scenes was a lot
of fun because the script was written
you know obviously when you have three
stories you have to cross cut you have
to find that right balance but also Ted
and I realized there's a fourth story
which is the NASA story so there's
really four that have to be balanced and
really it was just a matter of every
time we would watch the movie we would
scrutinize it and as we were honing it
down realizing you know there was one
cut we had I think the movie was about 2
hours and 15 minutes and it dawned on us
after a screening octavia kind of
disappeared for a while like of us and
she was gone for like over a half hour
and it was like that ain't right thank
you so much that was the Edit ID
so we just wanted to find that balance
and hopefully hopefully we did
jeno how did you guys bring Pharrell
Williams on board well he actually had
met Donna gelati are our co-conspirator
very early on in the process and and was
from the area and was aware of the story
and we were working with Pharrell on
another project had Mimi
so we already loved them and it just you
know all happened organically and Ted
the music is so amazing obviously and
it's so unique I mean so that's Benjamin
walfish and Hans Zimmer and for our
Williams together who did the score and
the soundtrack what were the
conversations you all had about what you
wanted the music to provide oh and I
first met for Pharrell I said I want the
music to hearken back to the 50s and 60s
but not be the 50s and 60s be something
modern take on that have like a his
modern tone in that style and he had
already been starting on some of that
stuff just on a whim and then he read
the script and he wrote he said you know
the Kevin Johnson group runs to the
bathroom 20 minutes back and forth and I
said yeah and so he wrote running like
the next week and then he wrote I see a
victory it's slightly thereafter so and
then and then we didn't have a composer
and Pharrell says what do you think of
do you have a composer I said not really
yet he goes what do you think of house
ever and I go well I guess right he's
available and then Hans brought Ben
walfish and they were they said this
music they kept saying this over and
over again this music doesn't exist I'm
gonna take something cuz Hans does you
know classic Hans German does classic
kind of euro music right and mixed that
with Pharrell and that really does not
exist and they kept saying we want
female voices so you're hearing a lot of
female voices in there in the choir and
and just throughout that's Kim Burrell
an amazing female vocalist yeah
it's trying to give an interview here
and so that's how it all all the press
we did is the first came Kimber Elle's
to like her she's singing or humming
over the Rockets in space and the
capsule in that space and so that ended
that feminine touch we really wanted to
be from a woman's point of view as much
as possible house and I another framing
device that I loved in the script is
this these moments where Katherine
approaches a chalkboard and happens I
think three different times and it's
just so powerful especially because we
see it as her as a little kid where did
that framing device come in in your
process just when I was looking at the
archived footage that was where you saw
them a lot of the time was at the
chalkboard and so I was like okay this
is where they live this is where they
think this is where they do their work
and it was something that I remember
even growing up and seeing my father and
my grandfather all working on it and
then I I think one of the big things for
me when I got this was I wasn't too
interested in their love lives at the
beginning for me I was like this is a
movie about their profession and their
minds and their math and I was able to
pull from my own experiences so the
scene with Janelle Monae I was saying
talk to me earlier where she comes in
and the professor says I don't know how
to teach a woman happen to me when I was
studying you know math in college and so
it always came back to put him in front
of those numbers and show them doing the
work the last thing I want to ask you
about is one particular scene that which
is that great kind of monologue that
Catherine just delivers when she's
completely fed up about the bathroom
situation and I love that moment it's
just so expertly done on your part and
it's the one time where we really see
her express all of the frustration and
emotion what was it like to do that
scene in contrast to all of the others
where you really had to keep it all pent
up that was that was definitely her her
her climatic moment you know that was
her breaking point every every human has
one I don't care how thin you are or how
controlled you are at the end of the day
you are human and we all have that
snapping point and she just snapped and
you know it wasn't even about
complaining it was just you know I think
for me as an actor where I started was
as a lady as a woman you know we we
spent so much time making ourselves so
pretty so wasn't even about the running
for her it was walking back into that
room looking like a wet puppy all of her
efforts her hair I mean she was totally
vulnerable and that's where I started
walking into the room with a roomful of
men and you're just so vulnerable
sopping wet
I mean that's I started there and it
just kind of escalated from there well
it's a powerful moment in a wonderful
film I congratulate all of you and thank
you so much
[Applause]